The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And a lot
of the women in this field,
about 20 of them, are
part of this co-op called
the Solar Women of Totogalpa.
And these women,
basically, they get
grants from different
funding sources
to research sustainable
energy options.
So one of the
things that they do
is they make their
own solar panels.
And the people in
the village can
buy these either with
money or with hours
spent working in the co-op.
So we decided that even though
they're making 60-watt panels--
does not match that--
but even though they're
making 60-watt
panels like these,
they also all have cell
phones, but a lot of them
are off the grid.
So they also need ways
of charging these,
and we thought that solar power
was a good way of doing this.
So what they're doing right
now to make these is-- this
is a poor image.
But basically, they take
the smaller cells, which
are 8 by 15 centimeters,
and these are rejects,
so they're not as
efficient as standard cells
that we might use here,
but they're much cheaper,
so they use those.
They might hand solder
them all together
and line them up, put
liquid silicone over them,
and then put a glass piece over
it, and then encapsulate it all
and make it look much
nicer like the ones you
saw in the previous slide.
So this is a much
smaller, much nicer
looking one that is made
in China and imported,
but it's available
for $20 in Managua,
which is about three hours
from the town we stayed in.
And so these are very
difficult to get,
and they're pretty
expensive, but they also
would like to be
able to make them
there so that it's
about the same price,
but it's more accessible.
It employs some people, and
it's just more sustainable.
So that's what we set out to do.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So
as was mentioned,
they do have access
to solar cells,
but unfortunately,
what happens right now
is to make the
cell phone charger,
they need to cut these cells.
And what they do is, basically,
they cut one of these cells
into four parts and then
attach them in series
so that the voltages add up,
so you can get up to 6 volts.
Unfortunately,
with this process,
what ends up happening is you
end up using a lot of the cells
just because the method
that they use to cut them
is not foolproof, and so you end
up cracking a lot of the cells.
And when you talk
to them, we realized
that they waste about
half the cells they cut,
which means that if they
needed to use 9 cells,
they'd end up using 18
because they'd waste half.
And so we figured that if
we could somehow step up
the voltage given by
three original cells,
they called these original
cells, if you could step up
the voltage given by
three original cells
to the required 5
volts to charge a cell
phone without cutting
them, it would save them
a lot of time and money.
And so what we decided to do
was connect three of these cells
in series, so you get
a 1.5-volt output.
And then have that output run
through your circuit, which
steps it up to 5 volts.
Now, the circuit
basically works like this.
So this is your input.
You have current inputting
data at 1.5 volts.
It goes through
your op amp and then
steps it up to 1.25
or 3.3, depending
on how it's connected.
For our purposes, we needed 5,
so we connected it accordingly.
These are capacitors, an
inductor, and a zener diode.
The zener diode is used to
make sure that the voltage goes
in one direction only.
And so basically,
these two leads
have a voltage difference
of 5 volts across them
when connected to the solar
panels and up in the lighting.
And what we did was, we then--
so this is we surveyed what
kind of cell phones are these
and realized that, for the
most part, they're Nokias,
and this is the most common
type of phone that's available
there.
And we got the adapter that
they used to charge this,
cut out the phone,
and attached it here.
If you look at our
prototype, you notice that.
So the orange and black
wires are these, basically,
and then they
connect to your port.
And then basically, the idea
is that you plug it in, put it
on sunlight, and
use this as a way
to make sure that you're
always facing the sun openly.
But there are a lot of
notches along the sides.
And so basically,
you wedge this in,
and then you can change
the angle of your panel.
So this is just a very
rudimentary cost breakdown
of what we estimate our cell
phone charger to cost them.
Basically, I mean, finally,
this is the number that we came.
We were trying to shoot for $20,
and we're slightly above that.
But we figure that there's
two ways to optimize costs,
and that is very viable for
them to get this for $20.
Yeah, basically, this is
just to give you an idea
how expensive the
components are.
I don't want to run through
each one of them just like--
GUEST SPEAKER 3: I'm
sorry, just to mention
a really quick thing.
We're also including
$4 for labor,
so even though it
is produced locally
and it is providing employment,
whereas the internet,
the China made one is not
providing any employment
for the community.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Right.
Exactly.
China made one cell
for $80, but they
don't provide any
source of income
to the people in Managua.
And so this is just to give you
an idea of the cost breakdown.
This is just a
blown-up image of us.
Again, just to give you an idea
of the components that we used.
Essentially, this circuit is
enclosed by this casing right
here.
So it's that circuit
basically, underneath this.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Which
you can see here.
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
Which you can see
that in that image, the
next image right there.
So I mean, like I said,
this is your output
from the solar cells,
which go into the circuit
and then go and
charge the cell phone.
And the actual
circuitry, so this
to talking about why we
made circuits like this.
We decided to use a
breadboard because when
you talk to Mario, who's
our community funder,
is one of the
community partners,
he told us that they do
have access to breadboards,
but don't have access to proto
boards, which we were initially
fine on using.
And so we decided to stick
with the breadboard, the model.
And we also, we figured
the [INAUDIBLE],,
the various components,
and they are available.
The only component
that we potentially
see having to be
shipped there is this.
But since they already
ship solar cells,
it would just be another
added component to ship,
and it's not very
good quality, so we
think it's definitely viable.
So that's why we decided to
go with the breadboard design.
Apart from that-- do you
want to talk about this?
GUEST SPEAKER 3: But
before that, I just
wanted to just speak a little
bit about the [INAUDIBLE],,
in general, why we chose
to build it the way we did.
First of all, it's
made out of wood
because they're really
locally-found material.
So first of all, I'll talk
about the solar panel.
So this is a solar panel.
Because we didn't have,
I guess, easy access
to the liquid silicone and
aluminum and plastics to use,
we still use acrylic
and a different method
to glue the cells.
In Nicaragua, they
make these differently,
and they customize it
for every application.
And so when we were talking
to him on the phone,
he already had to made some
changes to the initial design
and we had made, and he said
he would change the hinges
and everything.
And so it would be
made out of aluminum.
And so originally, we
wanted to make leg stands
so we could change the
angle and not just here.
But then we realized
that it might be easier
to put something in here
instead of having to have legs.
So we just came up with the
notches and cut a PCV pipe.
And then you can
change the angle.
Moreover, we wanted to create
a way to protect the circuit,
so we just encased it
around this aluminum frame
with the two wires hanging out.
Additionally, these are
really easy to switch,
so if you do have
another cell phone,
you could switch the charger
into some other cell phone.
And another reason why
this is over here, just
in case of rain.
I mean, hopefully,
you have it outside,
and you'll be looking at us.
Because it rains,
this is waterproof,
and it will also
protects the cell phone
and the charger for at
least enough time for you
to come and get it.
If it's raining really hard and
breaks, it's going to get wet.
For the long time, we realized
it really should be protected.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Right.
And like Juan
said, we could also
have another adapter going
out from the same leads.
And we actually do
have a USB adapter
that runs at the same
voltage that we did test.
But for the purpose
of the demonstration,
we decided to go with the Nokia
just because it's the more
locally available phone.
But we could potentially have
a number of different adapters
shooting out here.
It's all run on
the same voltage.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: So we're doing
some testing in the past couple
of days to see how much
power we could get out
of the cell phone, using
the lamp over there,
you can test it.
Make sure you have a
demo card, actually,
at work because it does work.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Do
you want to actually--
I don't think it's
going to stretch.
Do you want to just get this?
GUEST SPEAKER 3: So
here is the solar panel.
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
That's all right.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Can make
it incident to the light.
And you connect it.
They're charging?
So it does work?
You get scared for
a second there.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Well, there's
no way to stay charging.
It just has a little
charging symbol.
GUEST SPEAKER 3:
Yeah, so it does work.
However, we wanted to
see how efficient it is
and how fast we could
get it to actually work.
We realized that Boston-made
sun is not the same as Nicaragua
sun on the equator.
So we conducted-- there
are different lights
and light outputs.
This is the output power of
the light of the solar panels
calculated by just measuring
the current and the voltage
at the same time
as the solar panel.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER 3: And
the output power,
it's output power
are at least two
leads, calculated by measuring
the current and the voltage
at the same time.
So we are getting this.
So we then make a standard
for the efficiency,
and this is for the past
percent of the power
we're getting right now.
If we estimate for
Nicaraguan sun,
we would be getting
around 65% efficiency.
Right now, we're getting
about 0.2 amps in Boston.
I mean, 200--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: No.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: 0.02 amps,
20 milliamps in Boston.
if we extrapolated for
how we were getting
in Nicaragua with the
power in Nicaragua,
we'd be getting around--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: 80 to 100.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: --80
to 100 milliamps,
which in the cell phone
batteries are about 800--
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
Yeah, 800 milliamps.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: 800 milliamps.
So it would take about 10 hours
to charge the cell phone, which
is not ideal because
we were aiming for,
at the beginning was--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Five-ish.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Four
hours, five hours.
We're expecting 200.
The circuit said that
200 milliamps would
be outputted from the circuit.
But instead, we're
getting 9 to 100.
So it's not as efficient
as we would like,
but it still worked.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Right.
And just to explain why it's
so scattered at a point,
actually, above the 100%
efficiency mark, which
is theoretically possible, but
there was probably something
ahead of--
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
One of the times
we were using the actual sun.
And so it probably changed
a little bit in between.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: [INAUDIBLE].
That's it.
Thank you very much.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
Do you guys have any questions?
AUDIENCE: So how did you
estimate the Nicaraguan sun?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: We
took measurements
while we were there as far as
what voltage and current output
each cell was at
around 1 o'clock.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
based on what we think,
how much sun that
would relate it.
AUDIENCE: With
the 10-hour issue,
the only thing I think of is
the sun moves in 10 hours,
so the user would have to
understand that they would have
to move the--
so it might actually be
longer than 10 hours.
An optimal sun is 10 hours.
So it might be more like--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: The
one thing we noticed
was when talking to
people, they usually
didn't actually charge it
from completely discharged
to charged.
They usually charge
from about half charge,
so it would be more
like five hours, which
is more reasonable.
Because that's
more like the band
that sun is usable in a day.
AUDIENCE: How long is the
cell phone value life?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: We got
mixed answers on that.
We did about 10 to 15
interviews of people
and ask that question, and most
people, I think, on average
said they charged it
about once a week.
There was one person who
said once every 15 days,
one said every three days.
It just depends on
how much they use it.
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
It also, I think,
depends on how many cell
phones they have in the family.
Because we noticed that
some family had one cell
phone for the entire
family, so it,
obviously, drained out faster.
But if you have
individual cell phones,
they tend to last longer
because you don't need--
and so it really depends.
But for the most
part, like we said,
I feel once a week was a
very reasonable-- maybe twice
a week, I guess, on average.
Not if they don't use it a lot.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And
most of them just--
we noticed just from
living with the families,
a lot of the times, the cell
phone just stays at the house
so that if they receive a call.
So they can actually
still be using it
while it's charged
because they'll
be within hearing shots.
So if they get a call, they
can unplug it and answer it,
but they can't call it with
it while it's charging.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: I
mean, essentially, they
use a lot of cell
phone as land lines
just because they don't
have landline connectivity.
So yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: Just a little
bit about the community partner
we worked with, they
are called Asaprosar.
They're a human development
NGO based in Santa Ana.
They work in rural areas and try
to improve the quality of life
through environmental and
nutritional education, also
micro-credit opportunities and
general community development.
One of Asaprosar's
current projects
is introducing rice
cultivation in El Salvador,
both as a source of nutrition,
but also, as income generation.
And in order to prepare
rice for consumption,
it needs to be threshed
and also dehusked.
And current methods
that the community uses
are very time and
money intensive.
So our design
challenge is to develop
a cheap and local process that
dehusks rice more successfully
and conveniently.
The most important product
attributes that we focused on
are the efficiency and the
affordability of the product.
Our goal was to make sure
that more than 90% of the rice
was successfully
dehusked, while keeping
the price of the
product under $2.
We also looked at cost
and durability and safety
of the product.
And so after extensive
research and some brainstorming
exercises, we concluded that
the best approach to this design
challenge is to modify
an existing molino, which
is a corn mill currently
used in the communities.
The advantages are that
it's already available,
and it's being supplied
by our community partner.
And essentially,
what we're proposing
is inserting another material
between the two metal
plates of the molino that
would provide enough friction
to dehusk the rice grain,
but at the same time,
prevent them from being broken.
And some of the challenges
that we're dealing with
are the lack of precision
of the molino and then
also the fact that
it has friction
so that it wears
the materials down.
GUEST SPEAKER 5: So I'm going to
talk about the experimentation
process.
So initially, our
first problem was
to decide on what kind of
insert we wanted to use.
So we looked at metal, various
types of rubber and foam
and leather.
And when we were looking
at these materials,
we really evaluated
them on the cost,
how much residue do they were
going to leave on the rice,
how long it was going
to last, or how durable
and how available
the material was.
So when we did our experiments,
our two main variables
that we were looking
at were, essentially,
the type of material and also
the tightness of the molino.
So essentially, the
tightness was how much
space was going to exist
in between the insert
and the metal plates to
provide the adequate function.
And when we did our methodology,
our experiments, first, we
inserted the material, and
we controlled the spacing
by screwing the tab
all the way in so we
couldn't turn it any tighter.
And then we turned it a certain
number of turns back out,
so we knew how
much space existed
in between the
[INAUDIBLE] and the space.
And then we ran the
rice through the molino,
and after we ran the rice
through, we winnowed it,
and we separated
the rice into husk.
But when it was
still husk and if it
had been dehusked or broken
or the rice particles
or the leftover husk,
so the three particles
we were left with.
And these pictures
show the various types
of experiments we really did and
was quite an extensive process.
We experimented with various
different types of materials.
We would use one material and
varied the number of turns.
We might insert multiple
layers of the material
to see if that changed anything.
And also, we would run
the material, the rice
through twice and see if
that changed the efficiency
of the rice itself.
And ultimately,
what we decided was
that leather was the most
appropriate insert for us.
Because when we did
different material inserts,
we, essentially, found out that
it wasn't so much the material
that matters, but
it was the number
of turns that was really--
when changed the process
and the efficiency.
And we knew that
this material had
to be soft enough so that
the frictional and the torque
wouldn't break the material.
But we also knew it had to be
very durable because we didn't
want it to wear away, so leather
was the best option for us.
GUEST SPEAKER 6: So when
we're looking at leather,
we first decided that we
wanted to do unattached,
without having to glue around
here the leather to the molino,
it allowed for flexibility
for molino use,
and it had pretty
similar results,
and it wasn't hazardous if
we're not using some toxic glue.
We also decided with
brown, organic leather.
We didn't want anything that
was too processed or patented
or anything.
And we thought that one
piece might be acceptable.
Because it was similar,
we had similar results
on two or more pieces.
It's obviously cheaper,
if it's [INAUDIBLE]
and it's less hazardous if we're
not [INAUDIBLE] around here
together again.
So we actually were
worried about toxicity
after we learned about
tanning those kind of chemical
intensive.
We concluded though that
there is no dangerous exposure
because chromium 6 is the
most hazardous chemical that's
being used in treatment.
And it's actually broken
down into chromium 3, which
is an essential nutrient in
your body, so when it's inhaled,
it's OK.
OSHA says that 100 micrograms
of chromium protein or drinking
water is acceptable.
We found that that's
equivalent to eating seven
of these inserts a
day, so we don't think
anyoe is going to do that.
We also found that
there's not really
significant leather ware.
We process about 7/2
kilograms of rice,
which is a family's roughly rice
consumption using this concert,
and I'll pass this
around, but this
is a new one compared to
that one that we processed.
So you can tell that it
stretched a little bit,
but other than that, there's
no real wear that we found.
So we wanted to optimize the
process after we concluded
that leather was our material.
And so we processed about
1.5 liters at a time,
and we did a whole bunch
of different experiments.
We really focused on the
optimal tightness in the molino,
and we did this by
looking at the percent
that was husked and
the broken grains
and how fast we
could do 1.5 liters.
And then we also attached five
washers to the side knobs.
This is allowed for
stability, it allowed us
to better control, the
spacing between the metal
and the leather, so we could
really optimize our tightness.
So this is the data from
our experimentation,
so we found that using
the one piece of leather,
we get 94% to 96% husked,
which is really good.
And so our optimal outcome was
1% of unattached, four to five
turns out.
Looking at our original
project specifications,
we found that this was
very comparable to what
we have wanted, and
the durability we
are positive about a
lot of about 160 pounds.
So we estimated that
was our minimum.
So our final conclusion is that
one piece of leather unattached
to molino is at
best, 4.5 to 5 turns,
but the user can
vary that depending
on what they want as broken
versus dehusked grains.
It's very minimal cost.
It's about $0.50 per insert.
It's durable.
Again, we expected more
molino, but not too much,
and it's not toxic.
GUST SPEAKER 7:
So now that you've
heard a little bit of the
decisions behind the process,
I just want to take a little bit
through of what it might look
like for someone
that's in the community
and what they would have to do
to be able to use this process.
So first, they would have to
get a hold of a piece of leather
and cut it to the donut shape
that would fit into the shaft.
And if the molino body
wasn't set up already,
they would put it on
the stand and proceed
to put the leather on
the shaft and put that
into three of the
main body and then
continue by adding the
reservoir up on top as well
as the handle on the side.
Then the next thing would
be to add these washers so
that this brace can hold
the shaft in the main body,
but it can still
be tightened enough
and still leave enough space
for the leather to fit inside.
Then they would turn
the knob all the way in
and then turn out the
specified 4.5 to 5 turns,
or according to
their preference,
whether they wanted more broken
rice or more unhusked rice
and would then crank away and
put the rice in and process.
And from there,
separate the husks
from the grains by winnowing it,
using their preferred method.
And from there,
just as a side note,
we also found that when
we're doing our more detailed
experiments, we found that--
or to separate the broken
rice versus the whole grains,
we found that when we were
shaking it back and forth
in the sieves, the unhusked
rice actually came up to the top
just because it's a
little bit larger.
And so that gave a natural
separation between the ones
that still have the husks
on and the ones that didn't.
And so what we're
going to be suggesting
is to put the winnowed
rice into a container
and shake it back and
forth a little bit.
And from there, the rice
will then collect to the top
and gets to be able
to scoop it out,
and that's what gives us our
96% efficiency, and that's
the other contribution
to the process.
So from there, the
rice is ready to go,
and they would just have to
be washed before it's eaten.
So we just like to thank
[INAUDIBLE] and D-Lab staff
for helping us out and for
Will Floyd from Windmill Rice
or giving us our rice.
So if you guys
have any questions,
just thank you for listening.
AUDIENCE: And I would
say you did a good job.
GUEST SPEAKER 6: How
available is leather--
GUST SPEAKER 7: So we visited--
or I guess I didn't.
These two went to the--
GUEST SPEAKER 4:
We went to a store
in one of the town's
nearby these communities,
and it was a shoe store
that just sold leather
in massive quantities,
so it is available.
And the community partner
that we worked with, actually,
they were the ones
who brought us there,
so they would be able to
supply the communities
with the leather.
AUDIENCE: What fraction of your
rice remains broken at the end?
GUEST SPEAKER 5:
Probably about a third.
I mean, what we were
really concerned with was
how much-- like the
percentage of husk,
like the husk dries because
you can eat broken rice.
It's not as nice.
You would rather not eat
it, but for the most part,
we would rather err on
the side of dehusking
most of the rice versus
leaving at husked at all.
So about a third of it
was probably broken.
We lost maybe about
between 5% and 10%
of it was just like
sand, grainy sized.
So it was pretty good.
GUEST SPEAKER 6:
We have something
that people can
adjust the turns to,
so if they would prefer
having more husked rice
and just pull it out
themselves, then it
would probably be less
broken rice because it's not
going to be as tight.
It's not going to be
crushing it as much.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: And
something also, we
learned from the
community partners
that when they currently
bring it to a mill
to have it dehusked, and
when they get it back,
some pieces do still husks on
and some pieces are broken.
So what they currently have
is something similar to what
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And they could
theoretically cycle
the non-husked,
stone rice in and--
GUEST SPEAKER 5: Yeah, just
process it back through.
That's what we found was
really nice about it.
We weren't quite expecting this,
but when we were shaking it,
well, look at that.
All the husked rice is
right in the center.
So you just scooped
it all out, just
put it back with the rice that
hasn't been processed yet.
AUDIENCE: This sieve that
you used, are those--
GUST SPEAKER 7: Yeah, so
the fact that this is sieved
is irrelevant.
We just happened to use a sieve.
AUDIENCE: You were
using the sieve
to take out the broken rice.
GUST SPEAKER 7: Exactly.
Yeah.
And so it would just be a
fairly shallow container.
So the fact that it's a
sieve doesn't really--
it isn't the one that's
causing it to separate.
GUEST SPEAKER 5: But
we did realize though,
it was really important
that the bottom was
relatively flat and sturdy and
that the sides wouldn't bend.
So you wouldn't want
a plastic container
because you can't get the right
motion for that shaking back
and forth for it to separate.
So it felt kind of like--
GUST SPEAKER 7: But
we just, actually,
used the same container that we
were winnowing in, so I mean,
we don't have the huge
platters that they use,
but that would
definitely be something
that we'll suggest
to [INAUDIBLE]
and have them try it
out to see if it works.
JESSICA ARTILES: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
Our group project is Barrel
on Fire, Charcoal Desire.
My name is Jessica Artiles and
along with Vivian Dean and Kurt
Swoll, we went to Sabana
Grande in Nicaragua,
and we reintroduced and
re-helped the women make
charcoal out of agri waste.
So for context of charcoal
in the communities in Sabana
Grande, in 2009, a
professor, Amy Banzaert,
visited the community
and introduces charcoal.
Over the years, the
knowledge was lost.
The women lost practice.
They had challenges.
They didn't yield briquettes.
When they tried to
make it, they were
getting less than 10
briquettes per yield.
So we went this spring
break to Nicaragua.
We reintroduced the process
to four women, whom we now
call the Charcoal Captains.
And when we were there,
our yield of burns
were coming up to around
80 because of her burn.
Since then, we came
back, we redesigned
the charcoal-making process.
We made the
innovations, send them
back our feedback and results.
And when they've done
it with our new design,
they're getting up to 110
briquettes per burning.
So the project is looking
commercially viable for them.
They're looking at
making the charcoal
for the restaurant that's on
site to fuel and to cook with.
They're going to
be making charcoal
to sell to the community,
and they're actually
going to be displaying
it in their community
service in May on how to make
charcoal and how to sell it.
KURT SWOLL: So the
way that we identified
the problem was looking at
the current charcoal-burning
process, it requires
lighting this oil drum
on fire, which is
packed with dry biomass
and then sealing both
the bottom and the top.
So this process, right now,
with the barrel standing
on top of the three bricks,
is optimized for cost.
So this is the most
low cost way to do it.
However, we felt like we could
add improvements that would
be justified in their cost.
Because this has
two main problems.
One is the issue
of heat exposure,
so the user actually has to
get quite close to the barrel
to be able to kick out the
bricks from the bottom,
and the second is the
safety issue, where
in sealing the bottom of the
barrel, you have to tip it,
and this could result
in some accidents.
JESSICA ARTILES: [INAUDIBLE].
KURT SWOLL: So as
you can see, there
are flames coming out of
the bottom of the barrel,
as they're doing this, so
that's the heat problem.
And then as they're
tipping it, the barrel
fell over and almost
landed on one of the women.
So this is a safety
concern, and there was also
a lot of biomass to
the left of the barrel
so it could have lit
all that on fire too.
VIVIAN DEAN: So how
do we solve this?
Our solution consists
of a circular dugout,
a slightly smaller in
circumference than the barrel.
And within that dugout
stands three air channels.
And within each air channel are
two bricks that are embedded,
and the barrel simply
sits on top of the ground
and on top of the bricks
for a very stable setup.
When we tested our
solution, we wanted
to make sure that the biomass
can still be lit pretty
easily through the bottom.
What we found was that
biomass, actually,
it's a lot easier because
the air channels actually
block any wind that could
interfere with the process.
We also calculated the size
of the air channel needed
to be to allow the
necessary airflow for a very
thorough burn.
You can see on the sides of the
barrel is sealed to the ground
except for by the air channels,
and because the barrel sits
on the ground level,
we eliminate the risk
of having to tip over the barrel
or having to handle or move
the barrel while it's on fire.
Eventually, you'll
need to cut off
the air supply to the biomass
to allow it to carbonize,
and so the way we figured we
would seal these air channels
is through these metal plates.
So the idea behind these
places for the user
to be able to slide the
metal plate from a distance,
keeping a safe distance,
so that they're not
exposed to the heat as much.
And through several
design iterations,
this is our final
design we came up with.
You can check it out.
It's made out of one piece
of sheet metal, which
is very readily
available in Nicaragua,
and the handle is made by
making slits in the sheet metal
and curving it
around and riveting
it to connect at the
top, and riveting is very
available in Nicaragua as well.
So yeah, we just use metal
shears to cut the sheet metal
so it's pretty simple.
We have a video of
Kurt demonstrating
use of these new metal seals.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- All right, add the link.
Great.
VIVIAN DEAN: You can see
he does this pretty easily,
maintained a safe distance,
and it's pretty quick.
- Go for it.
Go for it.
- [INAUDIBLE].
[END PLAYBACK]
VIVIAN DEAN: And
that is our solution.
A big question that came
up when sealing the grill
was whether or
not we should seal
the bottom first
or the top first.
And we found through
experimentation
that it was easiest to first
seal using metal seals.
So we cut off air flow so
the flames aren't as intense
coming out of the
top, and then you
can throw on the lid
on the top, and then
that allows for smoke to come
out of any air gaps or air
holes, so you know where
exactly to plug sand in.
And now, to the solution.
We actually delivered
this to the [INAUDIBLE],,
and Jessica will tell you
about any feedback we got.
JESSICA ARTILES: So our
group is unique in that we
are able to have a native
speaker, me, to communicate
with the women constantly.
We kept communication
with them, through emails,
phone calls to
their cell phones,
to various women
and men on site.
And so this is a picture of
when they did their own barrel
dugout.
Again, we had our design,
and we submitted it to them
on a document of here's what you
should do, new and innovative.
And so they did the barrel
dugout, and they tried it.
They made their own sheet metal
designs to cover the barrel,
so we only send pictures of
ours, but they went ahead
and they said, we're already
going to make another design
iteration.
We love the idea.
We asked them questions
about how do you
feel about the safety risk?
And they said there's no risk
of the barrel falling over
now, which is just as
important as the heat.
We asked them how do you like
cooking with the charcoal now.
They said, I cook
tortillas, which
is one of the most
valued foods, and they
said, with the charcoal we make,
the tortillas were delicious.
I made a connection
with the charcoal.
They're going to be using--
arroz con leche, which
is like a rice pudding,
they're going to be
using the charcoal.
Now, that they feel safe
enough to continue to use it,
they're going to be
using it in the community
here this mid-May.
And lighting the biomass
is also an added advantage
because it was very fast.
All they have to do
is align the holes
on the bottom of the barrel
with the air channels.
And now, when they went to
light it, it was easier to light
because it was with protection.
So in conclusion,
in summary, we've
taken the
charcoal-making process
and added four points
of making it easier.
Four innovative
points to the process.
We've made the lighting
of the barrel easier
because now, when you're getting
the match under the barrel,
it's wind protected, so
the wind won't put it out.
Now, while the barrel is burning
for those 15, sometimes 25
minutes, it's cooler.
The flames aren't coming out
from under the bottom radially
out towards your feet.
Now, the ceiling of
the barrel is safer
because there's no longer
a tip and kick method.
All you got to do is
use the metal sheets,
and it's faster to seal as well.
Because it doesn't
require coordination,
and all you got to do
is slip the metal sheet
like you saw in our video.
KURT SWOLL: So throughout
the process of developing
the solution, we
did some experiments
around where the
heat was coming from,
and we discovered
that most of it
was coming from thermal
radiation from the barrel.
So we thought, OK,
a way that we could
improve our solution
even more is
to develop radiation shields.
And the gold standard
of radiation shields
is aluminum tin foil,
but we ruled this out
because it is just too
brittle and wouldn't
be able to withstand the thermal
cycles of a barrel burning
again and again.
So we experimented with
two others as well.
Here, you have window
screening, this
is made out of aluminum,
and galvanized steel,
like metal mesh.
And the conclusion was that
it wouldn't justify the cost.
The heat reduction
wouldn't justify the cost.
So you see in this graph is
the cost of insulation going up
on the x-axis, and
that's as measured
by more and more layers
of either the metal
sheet or the window screen.
And on the y-axis, you have
percentage of heat reduction.
So you do see a
positive correlation.
The more of that
insulation that you put on,
the more heat reduction you get.
However, spending upwards
of $15 doesn't even
get you 40% reduction.
So where does this
leave our solution?
Well, we think that the dugout
and metal plate seals really
represent kind of a sweet spot,
like in a range of solutions.
At the very top, you just
have the tip and kick method.
And then you can
introduce the dugout
and just seal the
holes with sand,
but that wouldn't give you
as much heat reduction.
And ours is medium cost.
The sheet metal is not
that expensive to make
the plates out of, and it
gets you a significant heat
reduction.
And finally, adding some
kind of radiation shields
is pretty high cost, and gives
you more reduction in heat,
but we don't think that it
really justifies the cost.
So we have a lot
of people to thank.
I won't read them
all out because I
think we are just about done.
But we are looking forward to
your questions and any feedback
you might have.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have an estimate
on how much each
metal sheet would cost
and how long you
think it would last?
JESSICA ARTILES: That's
a great question.
We thought about that a lot,
but when we introduced--
so we don't.
But when we introduced
the sheet metal,
they said, sure, we'll do it.
And again, they made one set of
this design of the sheet metal,
and they're ready to
make another set, so
another batch of
supplies to make
another set of sheet metals.
So it doesn't seem like it's
a restrictive cost for them.
KURT SWOLL: That is one thing
that we neglected to look into,
but we know it's there
on site because they
used this type of sheet metal
for their solar [INAUDIBLE]..
So we know they can obtain it.
VIVIAN DEAN: And
I don't think they
had to go out and
buy it for anything
because they already
had it in their center.
So our case is kind of
special in that they
do have these resources.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
the topping method still
involves getting
close to the barrel
where everything else maintains
a distance from the barrel.
Have you considered just putting
a top riveting, a small handle
on top of the top piece
so that you could also
put that on with your stick?
JESSICA ARTILES: That's
really interesting.
Actually, in the design
that the women made--
that's a good
question, by the way.
And the design that the
women made in Nicaragua, they
put a handle on
their metal sheet,
and they said that for our
second generation that they're
going to make, they're
going to take out the
handle because they realized
that it's unnecessary.
They said it's not that hot.
You can get close to it and
just insert it with your hands.
That's what they're doing.
So theirs doesn't even have
the little hole or the left
handle that we've
made for our designs.
So they're OK even without it
KURT SWOLL: Well, I think you
were talking about the top,
right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KURT SWOLL: Yeah,
they have one where
it's like the circular metal
plate that we have here,
and there's basically,
like a pot handle over it.
You just stick the stick
in, then you put it over.
So they have that.
AUDIENCE: OK, you
stayed on time,
so I'm going to
cancel questions.
Thank you very much, guys,
JESSICA ARTILES: Well,
you know where to find us,
if you have any more.
VIVIAN DEAN: We're
in the corner.
You can ask those questions.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BUS LEONARD: We're team OJ.
I'd first I'd like to
introduce the team.
I'm Bus Leonard.
BRIANNA CONRAD: Brianna Conrad.
EMILY ROSSER: Hi.
I'm Emily Rosser.
CARTER CHANG: And Carter Chang.
BUS LEONARD: So our project is
sealing the plastic bag sealer
that we developed during
our trip down to Nicaragua
over spring break when we were
in fact finding and analyzing
four different projects
we were looking at.
And we chose to develop
this one for the remainder
of the semester, for
a variety of reasons.
First, I'd like to describe
the situation we found
in El Roblar, which is the
community that we visited
in Nicaragua.
They have a large orange crop
that they get twice a year,
and it's very imaginable that
every similar community has
that same orange crop,
so they can't really
sell those oranges
on any type of market
because the market is flooded.
So the goal is to basically,
develop a way for them
to preserve that orange
product, and for us, it
came in the form of juice,
so they can sell when
there is a market for oranges.
So we presented.
This project was the first
developed in last year's class,
and we presented that
version in El Roblar
to the women of the community
who will be using this product.
And the presentation,
I thought we
had some technical difficulties
because we went down
expecting to be able to run
the device off of a 12-volt car
battery, but when
we got there, we
realized that since the last
group had gone down last spring
break, they had just
installed a micro hydro grid,
and they now had 120 volts AC
coming out of a wall socket.
And so nobody really had
the total car batteries
for us the power of the device.
So we strung up a bunch of
double A and triple A batteries
to be able to do a
couple of bag seals.
And there was a lot of
excitement about this device
while we were down there.
You can see we
gathered around it,
but we can only do a
couple of bags sealers
for the AA batteries
that we just
happen to have in our
backpacks were totally drained.
So that's basically
just the project,
to be able to create
something that they
can use in this
community and also,
be adapted to other communities
so that they can seal
orange juice or
whatever kind of thing
they're trying to preserve.
And they have a
pasteurization process
that comes before this
bag sealing that they use.
So this bag sealing is the
second step of that process.
And we worked with AsoFenix,
which is a Nicaraguan NGO.
They do sustainable
development and energy
work with many rural
communities in the area,
and I'll pass this
off to Rosser.
EMILY ROSSER: So AsoFenix,
we're incredibly grateful for
and helped us out a lot.
However, they rendered the
first prototype obsolete.
So we had a couple
of improvements
to make after this.
This was the first version.
As you can see, a kind of
permanent circuit that was
prefabricated, the
most expensive part
of the entire device--
a hinge that they had bought
and a latch that was of
sticky to pull.
Therefore, we wanted to
remedy this in version 2.0.
We also wanted to incorporate
a few of the things
that we learned in Nicaragua.
A, that there is not really
a reliable power source.
We wanted to promote
both DC and AC needs.
To do this, we got
an adapter that
can go from the wall outlet,
wall AC power, and output 12 DC
volts.
Also, you can just
take those same leads
and put them up to
a 12-DC-volt battery
and achieve the same effect.
Second help was this
pasteurization process.
We didn't really know much about
it for the initial prototype,
but after going to
El Roblar, we did
learn that the pasteurization
process is there.
We just have to
get the oxygen out.
So we had these two
parameters in place
while we were trying
to think of the design.
So the air removal process,
getting all the air out,
and ergonomics were also
factors in the design,
and this would lead
to us exploring
several different orientations.
First off, a vertical
sealer, whether it
was hanging off from the
edge of a table or dismounted
like that.
It wasn't really conducive
to user friendliness.
You had to hold
the bag in place.
It was of difficult
to get a clean seal
without any air in it.
It wasn't really the best.
Next, a handheld device,
kind of like a clamp
that you can just put in
place on the hanging bag.
It had a lot of moving parts.
We felt it wouldn't be the
easiest thing to scrounge
for those parts in Nicaragua.
It was kind of a lot of
fabrication involved.
Last but not least, we had a
horizontal sealer most similar
to version 1.0, the
prototype last year.
Our biggest problem with
this was A, it messy.
It got orange juice that
was running off everywhere,
and it was harder to get a
airtight seal as a result.
Also, just ergonomics,
pressing on it again
and again and again
was kind of difficult.
So in order to make the
best of both worlds,
we decided to combine both
vertical sealing and horizontal
sealing, the two most
feasible, and put it
at 45 degrees, a perfect
split at the offense.
Anyway.
So this is the CAD
model of our design.
The reason we wanted
to put it at 45 degrees
was to allow a path for the
runoff to go into a bowl
underneath, hence,
also why it's elevated.
Also, it's easier to smooth out
the bag and get all the air out
when you're doing this, a lot
easier to chop up the water
level or put the arm
down at the water level
and get all the air out.
So with this design in
mind, we eventually led to--
CARTER CHANG: --our
final product.
So as you can see
our final product.
is We decided on the 45-degree
angle for feasibility
and just for functionality.
One of our great
improvements is the latch,
so originally, the latch
was a wireless hanging out
that people would
have to manually pull
with a significant
amount of force.
But in this orientation, we
have a easy spring-held latch,
where all we have to
do is click and push.
It opens the OJ sealing.
And another improvement
is the circuitry.
BRIANNA CONRAD:
So first of all, I
want to talk about
the power adapter.
As you can see, we just bought
a plug-into-the-wall power
adapter.
We did look into making
our own or running things
without bringing the
power down, but we
found that this was the simplest
option and comparable in price
to any others, so
we ended up going
with the buy a premade one.
The circuit in the previous
design was very expensive.
It was a premade tiny board.
And one of the places that
the other team had actually
thought of as a
place for improvement
was to design a separate
timing circuit, so we did that.
We put it on the side here,
so the LED is visible.
It's just an LM 555 timer, if
anyone is familiar with those.
And the circuitry to
make it so that we
can change the time from about
3 seconds to about 30 seconds
for different
temperatures of juice
and thicknesses of
plastic and stuff.
So the wheel for changing
it is actually in there.
So you would set it, get
it right for one day,
and then put it back up.
And you turn it on by hitting a
button that sets off the timer.
There's a light here
that would go on.
We've actually got
it so the timer turns
on the micro heating element
for a certain amount of time,
which melts the bag.
And then the LED will stay
on for about 5 seconds
after the micro
heat has turned off.
Because waiting
5 seconds is good
so that the plastic
isn't still partly melted
when you're trying to pick it up
and so you don't burn yourself.
And we found that
counting it on your own
was very difficult,
especially if you're
excited about sealing your
first bags of juice and stuff.
So we made the LED stay on
longer to give a very clear
this is when you take it out.
CARTER CHANG: Looking at
the cost of our product,
originally, the version
1.0 cost about $56
for all the materials.
We were able to cut that
in half with the additional
functionality of our products.
We were able to ensure
that airtight seal,
in addition to have a
very usable latch system,
in addition to a
great timing circuit
that's compatible with
their AC power down there.
In addition to that, in
terms of implementation,
we plan to deliver our product
to AsoFenix via Amy in August,
I believe.
It will bring the
product down there.
In addition to that, we
will have a user manual
in English and Spanish
with user specs in addition
to additional circuits just
in case needing repairs.
And then also [INAUDIBLE] help
distribute to the end users.
We'd like to thank AsoFenix, our
mentor, Ken, Amy, Amit, D-Lab,
MIT, as well as the
Microsoft [INAUDIBLE]
for allowing us to
use their venues.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you have bags?
Can we see that now?
CARTER CHANG: Yeah.
EMILY ROSSER: If we can get a--
oh, sweet.
CARTER CHANG: [INAUDIBLE].
EMILY ROSSER: Everything.
Let's move their awesome
[INAUDIBLE] a little
farther away.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRIANNA CONRAD: This is dark.
Actually, someone
else can pour it in.
EMILY ROSSER: This is our
homemade, Nicaraguan orange
juice flown in
fresh this morning.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CARTER CHANG: So we
have the OJ in the bag.
We want to put a bowl here just
in case there's excess spill.
BUS LEONARD: So we have
this wire that's, obviously,
we're not using all of
the heating capacity
because we don't know
what size of bags
that they'll actually use.
They can be doing
personal-size bags
that they sell on buses or
other similar situations.
Or they could be making kind of
more wholesale litter-size bags
that they sell to
restaurants or something.
So that's going to--
CARTER CHANG: So have
the long micro wire.
Here's the bag here.
We have a little
guiding arm, so this arm
doesn't jiggle back and forth.
So we create our seal by
sealing it through the juice.
It's down here with excess
juice coming out into the bowl,
and you press the
button, the heat goes on.
And we should wait for it
to tell us when it's ready.
EMILY ROSSER: So we've
adjusted the timing
because we've been playing
with these bags all day.
The idea being
that you won't have
to adjust it if you're doing
large batches of bagging
your juice.
BRIANNA CONRAD: We
haven't adjusted it
since we left
[INAUDIBLE] this morning.
EMILY ROSSER: Yeah,
it's been really fun.
CARTER CHANG: [INAUDIBLE]?
EMILY ROSSER: Yeah, the 10
geometers inside that house
and so it's water.
CARTER CHANG: It's a seal.
There's the bag of orange juice.
Air tight.
AUDIENCE: Where did
the bags come from?
CARTER CHANG: So the
plastic bags that we found,
their similar
thickness to the bags
that were provided to us by
AsoFenix and by the community
partner or the
community in El Roblar.
BRIANNA CONRAD: You can
even purchase long tubes
and seal up the bottom and
then put the new same seal.
AUDIENCE: So they would
seal the bottom using that?
EMILY ROSSER: Yes.
CARTER CHANG: Or even just sheet
plastic if that's all you had.
AUDIENCE: And how
many bags do you
have to go through in
the adjustment process
to get it down?
BRIANNA CONRAD: I think I did
about three seals this morning
to get it set up right.
And that was--
AUDIENCE: And you could
do that with water here.
BRIANNA CONRAD: You
could do that with water.
I mean, it was this morning,
we started with the temperature
of the juice.
We'd like fresh from the store
juice, and it was all cold.
That added about 5
seconds to the time.
AUDIENCE: Pre-pressed?
BRIANNA CONRAD:
Yeah, pre-pressed.
EMILY ROSSER: So there
are a couple of variables
you have to juggle.
There's the thickness of
the plastic, the temperature
of the liquid inside.
Also, we found really
pulpy juice kind of
adds the time as well.
Hopefully, they wouldn't
waste too much plastic
in the process.
What we eventually ended up
doing was of making a seal,
seeing if it worked.
If it's nope, pull it down
an inch, make another seal.
See if it worked.
So we didn't waste that
much plastic on drill.
BRIANNA CONRAD: Yeah, it was
like three seals on one bag.
EMILY ROSSER: On one bag.
BRIANNA CONRAD: So there was one
bag that was not this pretty,
but still looked--
AUDIENCE: How are you
protecting the circuitry?
CARTER CHANG: So we have it off.
We used a silicon-base
adhesive around the base,
and we add that adhesive
around the LEDs and the switch.
BUS LEONARD: [INAUDIBLE].
CARTER CHANG: Yeah, PVC pipe
that's been spray painted.
BRIANNA CONRAD: And
the post clamp and cap.
We've got at least right
now so we pull it off
at the [INAUDIBLE]
and take it down.
CARTER CHANG: And just put a
flat-head screwdriver on it
and tighten it.
So it's watertight.
You can pour water on it.
EMILY ROSSER: Yeah, we
decided on using PVC
since that was actually
one of the cheapest
components we encountered in
hardware stores in Nicaragua.
It was something like
$0.02 per PVC connectors,
and I'm sure pipe
is equally cheap.
So yeah, just keeping
local materials in mind.
AUDIENCE: And is
the idea they would
make the circuitry themselves?
BRIANNA CONRAD: People
probably wouldn't.
AsoFenix has an
electrical engineer,
could probably make more or
draw out the best way for it
to be made in Nicaragua.
BUS LEONARD: We have a
circuit diagram that we used,
and that will be sent to them.
CARTER CHANG: It will be
part of the user's manual.
AUDIENCE: Is there any safety
on it [INAUDIBLE] burn yourself
[INAUDIBLE] or does it get hot?
BUS LEONARD: So I
guess the hope is
that you wouldn't plug it in
until you're ready to use it.
And then you would
follow the light cues.
But I guess if you're
moving it around,
you can press the button
that's on there it would go on.
EMILY ROSSER: The nice
thing is that when
it's pressed in place, it's
pretty much completely sealed.
And this is Teflon
tape, and the micro wire
itself pulls off pretty easily.
Teflon tape doesn't
pull easy at all.
We've been touching this
all day right after sealing.
CARTER CHANG: In
other words, you
can easily shut this down,
hold this with a firm grip
while it's on and
you still won't feel.
EMILY ROSSER: [INAUDIBLE].
BRIANNA CONRAD: If it does
get turned on accidentally,
if you were touching it, or
it got turned on [INAUDIBLE]..
It doesn't turn on the
[INAUDIBLE] or anything.
if the arm is open
for it to not turn on.
AUDIENCE: If they
wanted to connect it
to a 12-volt-DC battery,
what would they do?
BRIANNA CONRAD: We've got
these today for simplicity,
strung together, but you'd
just take these two leads,
and instead of
splattering, attaching them
to wires that are
in the adapter,
attach them tip
clips to a battery.